♪ O.
AINSLEY: DOZENS OF MASSACHUSETTS
STATE TROOPERS HANDING IN THEIR
BADGES OVER THE STATE VACCINE
MANDATE SET TO KICK IN
OCTOBER 17TH.
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT ALREADY
CRITICALLY UNDER STAFFED
NATIONWIDE, IS THIS PUTTING THE
PUBLIC IN EVEN MORE DANGER.
MIKE SHERMAN IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE STATE POLICE ASSOCIATION OF
MASSACHUSETTS AND A 25-YEAR
VETERAN OF THE FORCE AND HE
JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING.
SERGEANT, WHY ARE YOU FED UP?
>> WELL, THERE JUST HASN’T BEEN
TIME TO PROPERLY ROLL THIS
PROGRAM OUT.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF -- THE
DEADLINES ARE HERE UPON US AND
WE DON’T HAVE THE ANSWERS THAT
OUR MEMBERS NEED.
THOSE SEEKING MEDICAL AND
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTIONS HAVE NOT
BEEN TOLD IF THEY’RE GRANTED,
ARE THEY BE ALLOWED A REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVE TO WEAR A MASK AND
WEEKLY TESTING.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT, THEY ARE
LOOKING TO OTHER PLACES FOR
EMPLOYMENT IN THE MUNICIPAL
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE STATE OF
MASSACHUSETTS ARE OFFERING THESE
REASONABLE ALTERNATIVES.
SO IT’S NOT ACROSS THE BOARDMAN
DATE.
IT’S ONLY FOR THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH OF MASSACHUSETTS WHICH IS
AFFECTING MY MEMBERSHIP.
AINSLEY: STATE TROOPERS ARE
TAKING JOBS IN MUNICIPALITIES
WHERE THEY JUST GET TESTED AND
WEAR MASKS, RIGHT?
>> THAT’S CORRECT.
FOR THE NUMBER THAT HAVE FOR
WHATEVER REASON NOT RECEIVED
THEIR VACCINATION THEY ARE
CHOOSING AND THEY HAVE SUBMITTED
THEIR LETTERS OF INTENT.
THEY HAVE NOT OFFICIALLY
RESIGNED.
THEY ARE FOLLOWING THE POLICY TO
NOTIFY THE DEPARTMENT WITHIN 30
DAYS OF THEIR INTENT TO LEAVE.
AINSLEY: HOW MANY STATE TROOPERS
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
WHAT PERCENTAGE?
>> I CAN’T GIVE YOU PERCENTAGE
RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE STILL WITHIN THAT 30 DAY
WINDOW WHICH WAS ACTUALLY
CHANGED BY THE DOCUMENT ALLOW
FOR 14 DAYS.
BUT I’M VERY COMFORT BE IN
STATING THAT IT’S DOZENS.
AINSLEY: HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
THESE MANDATES?
YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN HEROES AND
HAVE DONE THIS SUCCESSFULLY FOR
THE LAST 18 MONTHS.
>> THIS DOESN’T COME DOWN TO
FEELINGS FOR THE MANDATE FOR US.
THIS IS ABOUT FAIR LABOR
PRACTICE AND MAKING SURE MEMBERS
THAT HAVE BEEN ON THE FRONTLINES
CAN MAINTAIN ON THE FRONTLINES
AND YEARS OF EXPERIENCE DOESN’T
WALK OUT THE DOOR.
AINSLEY: YOU DID FILE A LAWSUIT.
WHAT DID THE JUDGE SAY?
>> THE JUDGE DENIED THE LAWSUIT.
WE WERE LOOKING FOR AN EXTENSION
OF THE EXECUTIVE ORDER TO ALLOW
US TO CONTINUE TO IMPACT
BARGAINING.
AINSLEY: HERE IS THE GOVERNOR.
CHARLIE BAKER.
>> I THINK IT’S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THOSE FOLKS TO GET
VACCINATED, WHICH IS THE REASON
WHY WE MADE THE DECISION TO
REQUIRE EVERYBODY TO WORKS IN
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO GET
VACCINATED.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT RETIREMENTS IN THE
STATE POLICE OVER THE COURSE OF
THE PAST COUPLE YEARS.
I THINK SOME OF THAT IS
DEMONTHLIOGRAPHY.
WE WILL HAVE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
HARD WITH OUR FOLKS WE FUND
CLASSES AND RECRUIT AGGRESSIVELY
TO REFILL THE RANKS.
AINSLEY: WHAT’S YOUR REACTION?
>> THE UNFORTUNATE PART THERE IS
YES, YEARS OF NEGLECT IF YOU
WILL FOR NOT HAVING CLASSES AND
KEEPING UP YOUR NUMBERS.
WE ARE DOWN TO THE LOWEST THAT I
CAN RECALL IN MY 25-YEAR
HISTORY.
WE ARE -- A RECENT CALL-IN STUDY
SUGGESTED WE SHOULD BE 2900
TROOPERS.
WE ARE ABOUT NOW TO DIP BELOW
2,000.
I DON’T KNOW HOW WE ARE GOING TO
MAKE UP THESE NUMBERS.
THAT’S PRIOR TO THE POSSIBLE
EXODUS OF DOZENS OF TROOPERS FOR
THIS MANDATE.
AINSLEY: WOW.
HOW IS THAT GOING TO AFFECT THE
COMMUNITY AND PEOPLE WHEN THEY
NEED STAY SAFE AND WE RELY ON TO
YOU KEEP US SAFE.
THANKS SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
AINSLEY: YOU WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING?
>> IT’S UNFORTUNATE.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE HOW THAT IS GOING TO
AFFECT US.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE INCREASE IN
CASE LOAD AND RESPONSE TIME AND